uh listen if i was a viewer right now
and i i saw the title i saw the
thumbnail
i wouldn't like what i'm seeing bro i
really wouldn't
yeah yeah honestly
regardless of being a muslim or even if
i was a non-muslim i still wouldn't like
it bro yeah i was just about to add that
100
uh it's just there's just something
about you know
just
basic human instinct
where you see something egregious you
hear something egregious happening to
other fellow human beings
where your heart just feels for them
it's not something you want them to go
through and you develop you know care
for those people
uh so they
you know
see the title
people at least know is going to be very
interesting
inshallah inshallah
all right bro so
let's assume
someone's coming here and they don't
know who this jamaat guy is
because i'll be honest with you bro and
this is no low blow to the guy um i'm
not trying to you know make fun of him
right now
but wallahi allah is my witness
a week ago even like three four days ago
but i don't know who this was i honestly
didn't
billionaire investor net worth 1.24
billion dollars and i've never heard of
him
just goes to show you know either he
hasn't done anything that you know would
uh pique my interest
or
i'm just living under a rock bro by the
way bro a lot of people don't know who
he is so
i'm gonna give a quick little
introduction so
his name is chamath uh he's donated
about 250 000 to the biden victory fund
um he also donated 66 000 to the
democratic national committee in the
same year he also donated 750
000 to the ux us senate pac in the same
year as well so just showing like how
much power and influence he has he's
also uh
a part owner of the golden state
warriors so that's a nba basketball team
san francisco and
this is this is what he said in an
interview bro before i play this just is
there anything on your mind bro
let's go in
all right all right
so bro just uh give me one minute while
i pull this up yeah and uh
just talk to the viewers bro oh
bye
brothers and sisters
may allah bless you all dearly
i mean
um this chamath guy a little bit more
about him he's a sri lankan
refugee he actually grew up in canada in
ottawa
uh and he moved to america
you're gonna hear a little bit more
about him um probably after we watch the
video and and talk about him and just
the irony of what he says and
how it's ironic on many many many levels
uh so i hope you guys are excited for
that insha allah and to be able you know
to learn with us and to grow with us
uh to be better people insha allah and
inspire others to be better
me
and you know when you think about the
uyghur crisis you
i think the last thing you think about
is
you know the statements he would make
especially for all of society
and i i think you know it shows a level
of of self-righteousness of of
you know narcissism even
on this part
all right 36 viewers bro before we play
this video right now
quick disclaimer might be a little
disturbing to a lot of you
um if you are uyghur you are deeply
affected by this crisis or if you are
just just a normal human being just just
a quick little disclaimer that this
might not be something that will make
you feel nice and warm
on a friday right before jumaa so just a
quick disclaimer for that but uh yeah
let's just play it on bro all right
mr
[Music]
nobody cares about what's happening to
the leakers okay you you bring it up
because you really care and i think what
do you mean you care the rest of us
don't care i'm just telling you a very
hard you're saying you
i'm telling you a very hard ugly truth
okay of all the things that i care about
yes it is below my line well we i think
people if you if you explain to them
what's happening to the uyghurs in china
they care but it's not top of mind for
them that's not what's carrying mine
right now is they go to their grocery
store and the shelves are empty sure
that i care about yeah i i care about
the fact that our economy could turn on
a dime if china invades taiwan i care
about that i care about climate change
you know i care about a bunch i care
about america's crippling and you know
decrepit in healthcare infrastructure
but if you're asking me do i care about
a segment of a class of people in
another country not until we can take
care of ourselves will i prioritize them
over us
and i think a lot of people believe that
and i'm sorry if that's a hard truth to
hear but every time i i say that i care
about the uyghurs i'm really just lying
if i don't really care and so i'd rather
not lie to you and tell you the truth
it's not a priority for me and my
response to that is i think it's a stat
state of affairs when human rights as a
concept globally
you know falls beneath you know
tactical and strategic issues that we
have to have we need that's another
luxury
that's another luxury belief i don't
believe believing in the human
declaration of human rights that eleanor
roosevelt
i don't think it's a luxury belief to
believe that all humans should have a
basic set of human rights i think it's a
luxury belief and the reason i think
it's a luxury belief is we don't do
enough domestically to actually express
that view in real tangible ways so until
we actually clean up our own house the
idea that we step outside of our borders
with you know
with with us sort of like morally virtue
signaling about somebody else's human
rights track record is deplorable look
at the number of black and brown men
that are
far from deplorable look at the number
of black and brown men that are
incarcerated for for absolutely
ridiculous crimes i don't know if you
saw this past week but there was a
person that was released from jail
because he couldn't even be protected in
jail because in some of these cells they
run these fight clubs inside of riker's
island that are basically tacitly
endorsed by the corrections officers
that don't do anything and the top
friends so hold on jason so if you want
to talk about the human rights
of people
i think we have a responsibility to take
care of our own backyard first
first
and then we can go and basically morally
tell other people how they should be
running their own countries the
difference is chamath
saying what you just said in china or
saudi arabia would put you in jail and
get you a hundred lashes and you would
be tortured for a decade we here in the
united states are far from perfect we
still have the death penalty which is
against the united declaration of human
rights which we signed which eleanor
roosevelt created in the u.n
and we propagated as americans around
the world we started that chamoth
and
we can have these discussions about
being better in this country and the
what about ism that you're proposing
is
so um
disproportional
to the equivalent of the holocaust going
on we're talking about a million uyghurs
in concentration camps right now to talk
about what we have here that we need to
fix and compare it to that or to saudi
arabia whipping bloggers and throwing
gay people off roofs for being gay
these two things are not morally
comparable they are very far and we need
to have open discussions and talk about
human rights all the time because if we
do not talk about it all the time then
your position
which is i don't have time for that i
want to solve my problems then gives the
green light to dictators everywhere that
nobody's watching i need to have
vigilance and that and that's what i
find and i i think we need to hold on a
second
that's not what i said and that's not
true you said you can't get up for it
yeah so tell me how problem are you are
you saying that the the situation with
the uyghurs uh is the same as the
holocaust people who are jewish are
making that comparison you're never
making a mess i'm asking
upwards of a million people in a
concentration camp right now this is
getting to numbers that are actually
comparable it is actually a valid
comparison you're saying there are a
million people in a concentration camp
that is the numbers that human rights
organizations are saying between 300 000
and a million people are incarcerated
right now being tortured raped and in
doing for sterilization re-education and
when they're released are being tracked
in ghettos and so jewish people are
bringing this up hold on are you saying
you're saying the entire world has
basically decided that that doesn't
matter
you just said you can't get offered i'm
talking about you specifically but who's
getting up about who is getting up for
it i am very up on and i talk about it
all the time every week what about the
us government what are they doing about
it the biden just said we are going to
do a ban and we are going to uh sanction
companies that do business in that
region so apple and
tesla i think there will be increased
pressure on all companies that are
engaging in china overweight it's right
it's goods that are sourced from those
areas right correct yes it's not doing
business there's it's it's if your
supply chain comes from that area and
it's a first so kind of like we won't we
won't buy nazi goods but we'll sell our
iphones into nazi journal
well if you want to have a discussion
about this you know it's
how do we disengage from china we've had
this discussion here how what amount of
time will it take to disengage from
countries that have brutal dictatorships
that are committing human rights
atrocities against my look look i i
think i'm spending a lot of time and
money actually trying to fortify
america's supply chain you guys know
about some of the things that i'm doing
i'm not doing that from a moral
perspective i'm doing that from a
practical capitalist perspective
[Music]
brother that's a lot bro that's a lot
listen before we before we carry on a
lot of new viewers right now we got 97
viewers right now just outlook for all
of you for tuning in on this beautiful
friday smash that like button bro if we
got 97 viewers we gotta have 97 likes
minimum i think there's like 15 or 20
like what is this come on smash the like
button now we don't have time right now
because we're going to go in so i'm not
going to link it in the description
maybe i'll do it later inshallah but
check out our episode
with brother assalam hidayat on the
weaker crisis uh just type up the three
muslims weaker you'll see that um yt has
been notorious for shadow banning that
video what's new but please make sure
you watch that share with everyone you
can find all right now uh one pin
comment uh this is sticking yeah exactly
uh okay so for a lot of people that
don't know who this jamaat brother is he
is uh someone who is a billionaire
investor right he was one of the main
major initial investors in facebook
and uh i think zoom and a lot of other
things so he knows what he's doing with
with the money um this is what he said
this is what's been done in the in the
podcast that he has talking about the
uyghurs
and then 24 hours later on twitter this
is what he tweeted
i'm re-listening to this week's podcast
i recognized that i came across as
lacking empathy
mashallah bro so he has that awareness
i acknowledge that entirely as a refugee
first of all he wrote refuge not even
refugee but okay
my family fled a country with its own
set of human rights issues
so this is something that is very much a
part of my lived experience
to be clear my belief is that human
rights matter whether in china the
united states or elsewhere full stop
my man actually wrote full stop but
this seems like a pretty much canned
prepared answer that you see in like a
lot of these you know how to how to deal
with you know backlash how to do damage
control he just you know uttered some
words but rami bro
before you go and i just want to say
something right now
jamaat bro you're saying that
we as americans we got to get our acts
straight in our own backyard before
worrying about something else so what is
this whole war that's been going on with
the middle east like i want you to
explain this because they have this idea
that we need to liberate and and
modernize and save all these all these
muslims that are just you know sick and
and barbaric and and you know misled
so you're not you don't mind going over
to your neighbor's house for that regard
which there's no enemy by the way but
then when you look at china it's like oh
okay why are we doing why are we
worrying about that
like bro the cognitive dissonance come
on man just just say you're you hate
muslims bro like isn't that much easier
yeah and it is very hypocritical because
everywhere you look on the earth the the
people who are who are really really
suffering and i'm not saying people you
know there are there are non-muslims uh
and and none of them are suffering i'm
not saying that there are non-muslims
who suffer but if you look at the vast
majority of suffrage i would say in the
world a lot of it has happened to
muslims in muslim countries or muslim
minorities in non-muslim countries look
at bosnia what's happening there look at
you know the uyghurs what's happening
there look at palestinians and obviously
there are christians there as well look
at the palestinians what's happening to
them in israel uh it's it's it's very
very funny when people try and pit this
as not being a a religion issue or you
know an issue of beliefs in an issue of
you know intolerance so
just to talk about what he said and i'll
talk about his tweet later in sha allah
and and how sad that is but to talk
about the actual video and the
statements he made um if you as an
individual uh chamath want to talk about
how you don't care about the weakers and
how you don't care about what's going on
that's fine
we're not going to like it but that's
your own personal view and you know it's
for you to have and for us to dislike
but for you to put on everyone and open
up the entire discussion by saying no
one cares about the weakers
exactly who the heck are you to say that
about everyone if you look up a uyghur
petition you'll find there's a one
single petition i'm looking at just one
has over two million signatures imagine
the other petitions imagine the
petitions that aren't online imagine the
people who didn't sign petitions but are
doing active work like the the host of
that podcast who says or maybe he's a
guest as well who says he talks about it
every single week what about the uyghur
activists that talk about it every
single week what about all the videos
and and the podcast episodes that have
been made about it and all the awareness
awareness that has been spread about it
i don't think it's within your hands
uh
to say that no one cares about it i
think that is a very audacious thing and
you cannot afford that kind of audacity
to be completely honest
um
so that's clearly not true
the next thing he said
is it's below my line
now this i find particularly troublesome
because he literally just seems to be a
liberalist a secular liberalist a pure
capitalist and by the way pure just a
side note pure capitalism is something
only like the one percent are really
gonna fight for because pure capitalism
is that one percent should live in pure
bliss and everyone else should basically
live in poverty but since everyone knows
that majority's not going to accept that
instead of making it so clear-cut they
make it a little
less disproportionate
they make it a little easier they make
it social friendly and we literally
borrowed from socialists by having
social friendly markets as well but
that's aside the point him saying it's
below my line
just think about it if you know
standards
and standard and basic human rights
are below near below your line
then do you even have a line at all if
basic human rights are below your line
then where is your line
it has to be non-existent
because human rights
is is basically the very foundational
level of humanity it's been lawful that
every single human being
has fundamental rights
but it's a luxury belief in your opinion
to have that
well it wasn't according to
the
nearly 200 nations that signed the
united uh nations declaration of human
rights
uh which i'm just going to read a few of
these off here um article one says all
human beings are born free and equal in
dignity and rights they are endowed with
reason and conscious and we should act
toward one another in the spirit of
brotherhood um
that's one right another right is
everyone's entitled to all the rights
and freedoms set forth in this
declaration article three is everyone
has a right to life liberty and security
or person article five no one shall be
subjected to i'm not going to say these
words but you know
bad things
inhumane and bad treatment or you know
punishment or any of any kind and
article six everyone has a right to
recognition everywhere as a person
before the law and very funny enough
i would i would say one of the first
people one of the first nations to sign
this
on june 26
1945
was the republic of china
yeah say that one more time bro say it
one more time for people that weren't
listening
the first
one of the first nations
to sign
and ratify
the united nations declaration of human
rights
was the republic of china known today as
people's republic of china insane bro
they were the first people to sign it
and now they're the they're the the
one of the only people that you know i'm
aware of that are
completely going back on that completely
ignoring that and committing all these
atrocities no there's there's a lot bro
there's israel there's there's there's a
lot but china like what they're doing
votes it's unparalleled uh abdul malik
bro shout out to you for becoming a
youtube member he writes did that guy
really say or try to say it's not like
the holocaust he's using the fact that
holocaust has emotional connotations to
it to try to make it seem wrong to
compare the two pathetic hundred percent
100 like
well 100 percent especially as a as a
non-jewish person
yeah why is he
it bro exactly our civil rights we need
i
offended
about
to firmly hold on to the rope of allah
like really strong and urgently this
title wave of hatred is coming for all
of us let us be united in allah
i mean i mean i mean
they have a straight face and are
laughing about it now what are they
going to do when they meet allah in such
a state bro
see is the thing bro imagine knowing
about allah
and then you know saying all this and
then you know meeting allah and
whatever
that's that's one level of
sadness that you know
alhamdulillah that we're not in the
everyone watching inshallah
but to take it a step further not even
know about allah
not even know about your creator
let's say you're an atheist you're only
concerned with edonia you think you're
like feron you're going to leave the
world with all this all these riches bro
and just imagine bro when you don't
that's going to be the biggest slap in
the face bro
yeah yeah 100 may allah protect us and
again may allah grant us good deaths
before we uh we go on if we're going to
watch the rest of that if there is more
what i do want to add
is uh just a few more points about what
he made um
it's just i write i find it really funny
that he's speaking a lot about
um not caring and then he describes
uh what he even says to be not
prioritizing and this this is the ironic
part no one's asking you to prioritize
other people over yourself
we know that's like that's forbidden in
your self-righteous and liberalism and
we know that all you really practice is
to put your own personal pleasure above
everything else including your morality
and other people's well-being that's
literally
literally what liberalism would stand
for um the prophet islam
he says something very beautiful in
hadith he says
whosoever of you sees an evil action let
him change it with his hand
if he's not able to
then then with his tongue and if he's
not able to
then with his heart at least hate it in
your heart and that's the weakest of
faith so we're not asking you to be the
next like salahuddin
to be you know the strongest individual
in the world
and to stand up against this in a way
where you go and you fight with your own
two hands and and
uh all your resources we're not
we're just asking you to care
we're asking you to
feel something for these innocent people
just feel something and express that
feeling
or at the very least don't say that you
don't care at the very least don't act
like no one cares don't belittle the
issue and trying to say it's not like
what happened in the 1940s in germany
bro what do you say to people that are
saying
bro what if no one cares because i see a
lot of people in the in the hate
comments
in the video saying bro he's right
finally you know he's speaking out and
no one cares what do you say to that bro
uh i would say that again you guys fall
into the same idiotic way of thinking as
him the same self-righteous and and um
narcissistic way of thinking that he uh
has demonstrated and it's it's clearly
not true that nobody cares it's actually
very true that many people care uh just
because you aren't one of them and your
immediate friends don't get together and
talk about it doesn't mean they don't
care because what is care there's two
types of care there's caring for
and caring about
i mean maybe no one's caring for them
meaning no one's taking care of them
clearly but that doesn't mean we
shouldn't we're asking you to at least
care about them so we can get to a state
where we start caring for them
we're not asking people to to go and and
use their own resources to to stop
what's happening at this point in time
we're mainly asking people with no power
but with a voice to speak up and to
express your care and for you to say you
don't care about what's happening
just imagine if that was your family
just imagine if that was you just go
read the reports about what's happening
there because when we say these heinous
things are happening we don't just mean
like you know they're getting a little
slap on the wrist or something or
they're just like they're not allowed to
pray in public or something it is many
times more severe than that so for the
people that say no one cares again
uh who the heck are you to say that
about everyone and
on top of that for you not to care i
would say that's your own problem and
you can't stand for what your nation
class it claims to stand for uh again
that's a you problem something you have
to fix um
uh something else i want to add is that
he's demonstrated that
he doesn't even hate what's happened
what's happening to them
um he doesn't hate it and on top of that
he's again projecting his view to
everyone else and
i just want to touch on the point you
mentioned before
if america is so willing to invade
muslim countries in the name of
democracy liberalism and freedom then
why don't they have that same level of
moral standing when it comes to like
israel north korea china
why didn't they have that kind of
standing
america finally left afghanistan after
20 years
of being there five months ago
they finally tucked tail and run five
months ago
and while that was happening while they
were fleeing afghanistan
this was still happening in china to the
league of muslims so you can't have the
cake and eat it
you can't invade muslim countries in the
name of freedom liberalism democracy
not do the same thing when it comes to
the communist party
in china which is what they're called
hmm
share some numbers bro i know you have
uh there's a petition done
right and uh you know i was seeing some
of the notes so i'm going to that bro
and and do do do i said there's you you
had in the notes there was like a
petition and all the people and the
numbers we'll go into that because we're
not going to play the rest of the video
it's it's merely them just dismissing it
and kind of being like bro is it really
even there like i've seen a lot of
videos about people saying i need to see
it to know it's there but it's idiotic
bro but yeah i'm going bro yeah 100 so i
referenced this before and i'll
reference it again there's a petition
called stand up for the uyghur muslims
in china uh they their goal is to get to
three million three million signatures
and at the time of you know taking this
picture yesterday last night it was at 2
million 26 423 signatures this is just
one petition on one website of people
who care to sign petitions um not
necessarily just people who care about
them because there are many people who
care about them that did not sign the
petition i don't even know if i've
signed it personally but clearly i'm
sitting here and you know raising
awareness for them um so or maybe i
sound a long time ago
but regardless
it's um it's very clear that people do
care and it's again not within anyone's
right to say no one does especially
after so many people have expressed care
um for them
so
he also says
the reason i think it's a luxury belief
is because we don't do enough
domestically to express that view
so since
we don't do enough to express a certain
moral view we can't have that moral view
so
if taking someone's car and driving 20
miles ditching it and running away
is something you're against
if you can't stop that from happening
100 of the time then you have no right
to have that moral standing is that what
you're claiming that all your moral
views that you cannot fully 100
um adopt implement and stop uh you know
against happening to the rest of the
world
are nothing
if that's truly what you believe
um and then he says
he basically after talking about
wrongful convictions he talked like he
talks about miscarriages of justice and
everything
uh in the united states judicial system
he says if you want to talk about human
rights of people i think we have a
responsibility to take care of our own
backyard
first and then we can go and tell other
people how they should morally be
running their countries now why can't
you have both
why can't you condemn
and hate
an ethnic cleansing
while fixing your own judicial system
one immorally run prison i don't know if
we got to this point in the video where
he mentions it but one immorally run
prison in the u.s
should that really take our attention
away from an ethnic cleansing in another
country
that's very disproportionate
and um after the host compared the
genocide in china to the holocaust
honestly at that point i see it's it's
basically over his responses after that
it's basically done because after that
all he does is throw up red herrings
which is a red herring is like a stinky
fish that you wave in the path of
running dogs to get them to go elsewhere
is trying to mislead the conversation
elsewhere
he also brings up straw man arguments
which is trying to misrepresent the
points to make them sound dumb um which
the host or the other guest did an
amazing job
of counteracting these very stupid um
fallacies i just wish she pointed them
out directly so people could see more
clearly for those who don't you know
recognize you know these these fallacies
that people use um but yeah you can
basically see us over because he begins
to straw man throw it herrings and not
being able to you know to defend his
position he asks are you comparing it to
the holocaust as if 300 000 to a million
people in these camps is not bad enough
as if people being you know treated
heinously even if it's 20 people as if
that's not bad enough and
imagine like first year world war what
the numbers were imagine six months of
the world war what the numbers were you
know a lot of people denied it for a
very long time and america only got
involved after
uh pearl harbor was attacked
that's the only time they got involved
after being attacked uh basically
themselves
so
that is facts
reader bro
the reason chamas said
this is because he's a well-known stock
trader and we need to maintain free
trade with china for stocks and economy
to do well 100 and this is something
that he alluded to towards the end that
you know the whole app like you know
apple makes their products in china
should we stop you know
completely cut trade with china and stop
selling iphone stop having iphones and
all these different things and it's like
if you cannot bring yourself to fully
economically sanction china that doesn't
mean that you can't still put stress on
them and if your country is too unstable
weak and reliant on china to make a
difference then at least
stand against it and urge other
countries to stand against china if they
end up doing an economic sanction
against us
then you know both are going to suffer
um and then maybe that would actually
eventually lead to some kind of change
in the future
so
final few points here
he says but who is standing up for it
as if he can't speak up for himself and
he needs other people and politicians
and certain governments to speak up on
an issue before he can even acknowledge
it when they have demonstrated in the
past that they are not always willing to
get involved because of their own uh
selfishness essentially
look to world war two you will see that
how did it get to the point where six
million innocent jews were were you know
without using gruesome terms treated
that way and that's a very like very
super light term to use uh treat it that
way obviously i'm sad that i have to use
that kind of
uh yeah bro it's to add on to your point
bro just look at what he's saying like
all the things i've done look at all the
things i've started all the other
organizations all that and then he says
i didn't do it for morality
i did it for for capitalistic gains
yeah
nick you're telling yourself bro
yeah like you want to keep that in the
business world i get it bro because you
need some level of self-interest and
disagreeability to success in business
but when it comes to the world and what
really matters bro you can't be applying
that and being okay if i don't make
money on this if i don't get clout on
this then i'm not going to talk about it
bro we could literally be like yo we and
by the way guys i just want everyone to
know that we've been speaking about the
uyghur uh you know crisis in all the
episodes
i think when we had like two or three k
subs bro
and i could be like oh i'm gonna wait
till i have 100k to talk about it
because you know because and then some
might argue that we only got like a
thousand views at that time like that's
not even that much but we don't care
about that we don't care about views or
anything like that i'm still gonna you
know after this video's done processing
link it in the description in this video
if we had 100k if we had a one mil
we'll get more viewers but even if we
don't even if we inspire one person to
just learn about it study it talk about
it put something on your story like
we've done our job
and we can't give up until everyone
around you is aware of this issue like
so i don't have you know
white people
african-americans asians muslims
non-muslims everyone around me they know
about this issue
and you're out here saying that you're
really saying like everyone knows about
it but they're doing nothing
like bro
it's sad but it's true
yeah
yeah 100
100
and you know what's what's very funny is
usually chamath would be a person to you
know stand for something like that if
you go to a website called a social
capital
company also called social capital if
you go to the website
you'll see on it it says
at the very top the very front of the
pages our mission is to advance humanity
by solving the world's hardest problems
and if you go to who the founder and ceo
of social capital is you'll see mr
chamoth himself is the founder of this
this business which is claiming
that their mission is to advance human
society by solving the world's hardest
problems why you're not willing to solve
the hardest problem of you know let's
say ethnic cleansing
racism discrimination
against you know certain people certain
beliefs certain color so on and so forth
no i don't get it bro i really don't and
it's almost like you saying you're a
refugee bro you saying you're you've
left and he's a sri lankan by the way
and you were saying i've had my own
human rights you know issues and this is
a part of my lived experiences
and then you come to the west you find
the american dream
you know how to make money
you get to the top
and all of a sudden
yolo whatever happens to those people
it's on them they can save themselves
just like i had to save myself what kind
of mentality is that bro yeah it's very
very very hypocritical and it's this is
why i wanted to save the tweet for for
the end because it's so
it's it's very funny to be completely
honest
and who helps fund him think about it
america bro
yeah yeah
so shameful how the muslim world leaders
are sitting silence upon allah there
will be a question for this it's beyond
appalling
100 percent
um what will happen then on the day of
judgement i'm happy that i'm not um
uh and may allah hold them all
accountable but if you look at that
tweet him
really just saying
like he's waffling to be honest he's
saying a lot but meaning nothing because
all he's showing is that he's a
hypocrite that he is claiming to go
through something similar to what
they're going through because he had his
own human rights issues he struggled
with as a kid and he was fortunate
enough to find refuge
he's fortunate enough to get away from
that
what about the muslim wiggers who can't
why don't you have the same level of
empathy for them that you had you have
clearly for yourself you're the young
version of you uh you know finding
refuge in canada
or fleeing from sri lanka why can't you
have that same level of empathy and care
that you have for yourself for the
weaker muslims it's very hypocritical
bro i agree when i was doing a little
bit research into them i live in
waterloo right now which is a city in
canada and subhanallah this man went to
the university of waterloo bro
[Music]
like just hearing that i'm just like bro
i gotta move out now
abdul malik i don't know if it's still
uh where you're or not
but make dua for them on the last hour
of friday last third of the night and
other times mentioned the sunnah
inshallah we muslims need to learn our
deen stop sins and hope will come in sha
allah
um
yeah so i know i spoke a lot i want to
give the mic to you if you have anything
to add before i uh keep going here
no bro i think you're on a roll and
there's more points that should be
discussed i have one that i'll save till
the end but go in bismillah
yeah
so i just want to also comment on
something you mentioned before about um
his basically his capitalism that he
does it for capitalistic gains for
america's economy and all of that and
it's very distasteful honestly it's very
distasteful i think for a lot of people
to hear that
the reason because he's a person
who you know has had articles written
about him on how he claims to want to
help the 99
he's you know definitely within the one
percent definitely within the one
percent
uh and he wants to help the 99 that's
what he claims and now everything he
does
to help the 99
he's only doing it for economic reasons
he's not doing it because he cares he's
only doing it for
capitalism the sake of capitalism
and
why are people so attached to to this
capitalistic view
because
what does it say what does it claim
it claims that there should be a one
percent of people who thrive and
everyone else should not thrive as much
and now we see it as fair because we
live in this kind of society
but is that what's morally right this is
the problem when when men try to govern
themselves they have bias they have love
for money they have limited information
and the people at the top are going to
stay at the top they're going to want it
to be that way but could we not produce
a a society or way of living an ideology
that's a little more fair and i'm not
saying socialism i'm not a socialist i'm
a muslim and islam has its own political
theory economy ideology and all of that
social theory and everything
so
let's escape from this capitalistic
lifestyle because honestly it's very
self-conceited it's very selfish and it
has the majority of people suffering if
you look at the middle class
in canada it's being wiped out as we
speak
house housing prices are going up
everything's going up actually inflation
is affecting everything
you know bro imagine 50 worth of
groceries like a decade ago compared to
now
you can get like some eggs some bread
some bananas
some milk
a few apples
and like maybe some oil to to
make whatever you want to make the bread
that you can't afford in the future
and
like literally that's 50 right there
housing prices going up most people are
suffering man
no one's talking about inflation bro
subhanallah and by the way guys just
like we do at the end of uh you know the
last few minutes of an episode we've
just opened it up to subscribers only
for the member chat so it's not gonna be
members only so please feel free to
do your thing now and for next episode
just for future reference um
anytime we do topics like this anytime
it's important
uh you guys want to spell you know help
the cause let's say you don't have money
because we we're going to try to include
a you know multiple charities in the
description but let's say you don't have
money to donate
donating to us is already i'm already
telling you like we have plans to build
a masjid and these things are going to
happen inshallah this year too i don't
want to make any promises but we'd
rather you know show our effort than
just speak on it
but donate to charities and if you don't
have you know money and and provisioning
to donate to charities
make sure you do your part by just
liking a video and sharing because you
have no idea how many people would
benefit from this and maybe they'll take
action maybe they could be the next
person that makes that you know impact
in their community
subhanallah but there's my right so
where's the president and then iran
speaking against chinese yeah muslim
leaders need to stop
yeah 100 bro 100
this and and also a lot of people say uh
what is this country doing what is that
country doing i'm not gonna name any
names but aren't they muslim countries
bro there's no muslim country today
there's muslim majority countries but
muslim majority countries are not doing
anything because they're from the
majority of the west in terms of mindset
which means they're only you know
worried about you know money the only
worried about material gains power
control that type of stuff they don't
really care about the sharia and and
allah's you know
divine revelation they don't care about
any of that so i get it like a lot of
people are saying what are all these you
know muslim countries doing what are
these leaders doing it's a sad state of
reality bro but it's i know we don't
expect it it's not how it should be but
this is the way it is um brother ismael
also wrote that the muslims need to get
there you know we need to stop sinning
and i think it was him or it was abdul
malik and he's right bro because if
muslims if we get our act together and
we make dua bro
don't think that allah is not going to
answer to us
yeah 100
and um
the prophet sallam he said when he was
asked
by a person by sahabi should i time my
camel or should i trust on allah because
he kind of saw it as a contradiction
that he's he's trusting in this like
this pole this fence and this rope to
hold this his you know camel in place so
should he trust allah or should he tie
his camel
and trust in allah so we do trust allah
to deal with these people and allah will
at the very least or at the very most to
be honest on the day of judgment
but we still have to make our effort you
guys still have to share this video we
still have to keep you know producing
content like this we still have to keep
speaking out against people like like
chamath and
and uh very selfish individuals with no
level of honest morality except for
themselves and probably the ones around
them and the one percent
[Music]
yeah sorry you're right and uh why do
people expect countries 100
waiting for a president i i hate to say
it in a way but i'm going to say it
anyway
i don't think there's a single country
right now in the world single nation
state that i would genuinely
ideologically fully submit to i don't
because one the only thing i will is the
sharia and there's no country properly
enacting that uh which is unfortunate
but this is the state of reality today
uh however when you look at waiting for
leaders bro what is that gonna do
me waiting for my leader to tell me i
don't have to wear something on my face
before i go outside what is that gonna
do bro like
all this oppression and injustice and
these backward rules that are going on
today that make no sense by the way
about a lot of things we're not gonna
name any names now
um what is that gonna do bro waiting for
your leader to be like okay i'm gonna
you know what's happening to the weaker
isn't right what's that gonna do bro we
already know allah gave you the fitra
bro justin trudeau
in uh you know the prime minister of
canada
uh majority senate right
completely didn't act in favor of you
know deeming china as a genocide bro
this happened this is reality
like does that mean oh because jp said
it's not right uh or we should dismiss
it we should dismiss it what type of
mentality is that just because this
muslim leader is not doing anything
about it therefore uh islam stands for
the oppression that's happening what
type of sick mentality is that bro where
is that going to get us bro
the prophet saws when he came to to
spread islam and spread tauhid bro he
turned all of arabia upside down nobody
agreed with him forget you know one
person took nobody initially you know
barely and i'm being being figurative
right now nobody agreed with him
does that mean you know he should just
give up and he didn't bro so i saw him
um where's this this sunnah mentality
gone bro nobody has that anymore
yeah yeah and this is something we need
to
bring back and this is something that if
we bring back to the ummah
honestly we will honestly really start
solving problems but the issue is we are
involved in liberalism we are involved
in the western way of life we are
involved in we have completely given up
our beliefs
almost completely given up our beliefs
our morality
our love for religion our love for allah
and we've literally replaced it with
western life western ideology western
thought western morality and it's
honestly a shame
we have our deen we have our moral
standing we don't need to wait for the
west or for muslim leaders or for
non-muslim leaders to stand up and say
something especially when you have
leaders that they themselves are
committing these heinous crimes
especially when you have someone like
justin trudeau who's willing to say and
this is a controversial issue so i won't
say certain things but he's willing to
say that certain types of mandates
are against
human rights
but we're going to do it anyways that is
literally what he said there is a
conference he said certain mandates are
against your human rights but due to a
loophole we're going to do it anyways
and we're not going to go deeper into
that but i'll probably put the link in
the description but basically saying all
these mandates saying you know that we
can't do a lot of things today right i
know you guys know what i'm talking
about half the world is you know shot
down right now with all these
restrictions but um for canadians if you
guys don't know we're her hardest bro so
those that are telling you you can't do
this you can't go here you can't do this
we can't do that because it goes against
the law but we're going to do it anyway
he literally said this explicitly so
subhanallah bro ismael writes again what
are your thoughts on brother and skender
of the boston celtics bro mashallah very
proper brother uh i believe he has 1.1
million followers on instagram i just
checked yesterday
oh my god fide you only care about
followers no it's not that bro is the
fact that he has 1.1 million followers
and look what he's doing with this
platform look at the amount of posts
he's making by the uyghurs look at the
amount of posts he's making about
injustice
that's what you call using your social
media platform you get what i mean
yeah look at look at someone like uh
you know
elon musk
right or i'm not gonna say elon musk bro
because what he's doing it still matters
to him and and he's trying to do it in
his own way but but people you don't
have to be a social justice warrior
that's what i'm saying you don't have to
dedicate your whole page to like just
fighting for people's causes
but do something bro talk about
something stand for something bro and i
see too many people they just have way
too many followers and and they're not
doing anything about it and when people
ask them yo why don't you talk about
this oh i don't want to talk about this
because i'm going to lose followers
oh i don't want to talk about this
because what are people going to think
you know
yeah yeah and you know what it's so
funny and it's all a matter of
perspective and this is the problem
with uh putting things like money and
fame and wealth first because if you had
the perspective of i'm gonna post it and
whoever unfollows me because they don't
like it i don't want that person
following me anyways it's actually a
better thing if you think about it it's
just cleansing your follower list of
people who are toxic people who are
immoral people who are obnoxious so if
you have a billion followers or a
hundred thousand followers or something
of a high caliber or even if it's just
ten followers to be completely honest
and you're worried about sharing certain
things like the weaker crisis because
you think people are not going to like
you
it's i would rather
i would rather have people kill me
maybe i shouldn't use that word but
go at me and dislike me
because of something i stand for that's
correct morally then the people like me
than to have them like me
for not standing for anything at all
because if people like you when you
don't stand for anything then they don't
really like you because they don't they
don't have anything to like about you
they just don't dislike you yet
as muslims bro we gotta be honest we
gotta be authentic like
if i had six people bro i would rather
have three of them
love me for everything i am and three of
them completely hate me but all six of
them know me very well then i have six
people that kind of like me because when
i'm around them i change my personality
i change my my vibe just you know agree
with them and just like i'm kind of fake
you know i don't have an identity i just
want to be liked by everyone i'd rather
be the former bro any day
you want to read this up bro
the the quote from golden mayor
when they burnt al-aqsa mosque she was
so she was so afraid the muslim armies
would come the next day
she said when they didn't come she
realized they could do anything they
want awesome
wow
well it's very true and it's very
unfortunate and you know i want to tell
you guys a story a story that my teacher
once told me just so you know the
strength of the muslim just so you know
the strength of the ummah
there was one and i don't have i don't
remember the details unfortunately but
there was one muslim woman
who
lived in a certain land and she was
locked away
in a cell in that land
unjustly unfairly
and she told the leader of the land
that i'm going to write to the khalifa
and he's going to come and deal with you
and he's going to set me free the
khalifa the leader of the muslims at the
time she wrote a letter to him it got to
him he told his army
we're going now they literally left
right away they went they went to the
land
they they and when they got there by the
way he says no one opened her
her cell he said i'm going to be the one
to go and open the cell myself
that was the leader of the muslims he
went
and he opened her cell himself
and freed her himself
there's no muslim a leader doing that
today but we don't need them
what are they gonna do they they have
wallah they have nothing if they don't
have integrity they don't have dean they
have nothing they're weak we don't need
them your job is to look at life through
an islamic lens learn what it means to
be a muslim look at life as a muslim
don't look at life as a capitalist as a
liberalist
look at life as a muslim
and know that with everything you see
allah sees it as well and allah says you
and allah knows what you think and allah
knows what you're going to do
see islam through the eyes of a muslim
through the eyes of the prophet
and holds on to the religion tightly
and everything you see
everything you see
catch yourself when you see it through a
liberal lens that no this is okay
because they say it's okay
what about what allah says and if you
can adopt that mentality and that
strength and everyone in the ummah
adopts that kind of strength
then we will finally be able to honestly
stand up against injustices like this
when we can put other people
before our own selves
subhanallah
that should be a clip bro on tick tock
i know it will be inshallah but
as we wrap up this podcast unfortunately
again because we could go for days but
we could go for hours uh you know we
have some new changes that i want to you
know quickly discuss bro tell me if
there's nothing else on your mind
i'm good
starting next week guys
and this is just for the realist 86
viewers that's made it this far all
right
next week onward so this is effective
immediately so for monday
we are switching up our schedule
we will no longer be uploading
videos
like we're uploading and going live like
we're going live this is not this is not
to say we're not gonna be uploading and
we're going off youtube and we're just
gonna you know screw off and just move
to like an island and just leave
civilization that's not what we're
saying
what i'm saying is
we are only gonna be going on live 7 30
p.m eastern standard time it'll no
longer be
noon
this is the only time zone that works
for all three of us now
because
me
myself
angel
and brother rami right here we do not
live
in close proximity to the point where
all three of us have aligned time zones
where we can do like you know convenient
times
therefore we're only going to be doing
live streams at 7 30 p.m eastern
standard time
two days a week insha allah from next
week on it'll be monday
and friday
so inshallah we're gonna have two live
streams a week now not just one per week
and you know multiple reaction videos
insha'allah throughout the week
and that's what's going to be for the
indefinite foreseeable future and we'll
let you guys know if there's any changes
um and yeah bro anything you want to add
no just uh
again share this video
um
we're all gonna return to allah we're
all gonna die the leader of the
communist chinese communist party is
gonna die
i'm gonna die you're gonna die at the
end of the day we're all gonna return to
allah and they're going to be held
accountable and we're going to be held
accountable for what we did and didn't
do just remember that inshallah share
the video do your part and at least on
the day of judgement you can say allah i
shared this video
so we can spread awareness because i
couldn't do xyz myself
i mean i mean i mean
100 bro
i just want to quickly address something
bring
angel back i know you wrote angel
um
on ho
i hate to i hate to say it bro
but uh i think we should let the viewers
know right that we're gonna change the
name to the two muslims it just didn't
work out with him he's no longer gonna
be a part of the podcast
um no i'm just playing bro
that's far from it angel
after his travels because uh he is he
was traveling
he is now in quarantine bro he has the
quarantine for two weeks right
and it's kind of annoying bro
quarantining and then streaming and you
know all this because where your app
might not have the best wi-fi so don't
don't be you know don't trip on that
monday just like i said monday we start
the new schedule
7 30 p.m eastern standard time for the
live stream and friday
literally from monday he'll be there so
inshallah don't worry about any of that
uh i know you know a week or two without
angel it was crazy i'm personally you
know i'm very very disappointed very sad
and just heartbroken bro that he wasn't
here he is uh you know the life of the
party but inshallah monday on
he will be there
insha'allah inshaallah
yeah that's always a blessing happening
there's always a lot you know lighter
when you say allah
and guys i just want to say any of you
guys right now that hasn't he hasn't
caught our episode with brother musa
adnan please catch that it's and we're
not saying this for views because if we
wanted views i'd give you something way
more views but our realist videos don't
get the most views
it's reality right this was one of our
realest videos bro
the stuff we talk about in this it's
just for the average muslim i want
everyone to just listen to this renew
this and constantly keep this in their
mind
just embed it deep into your skull
because when we go through things we
often forget these things so if you're
in a state right now where you feel like
okay life is good alhamdulillah
money is money is good alhamdulillah
food is on the table alhamdulillah
relationships are you know thriving
alhamdulillah now is the time to watch
this video because when things are not
optimal we usually tend to forget and go
into this like stress scenario and these
things don't come to the forefront right
so if you feel like you're not depressed
you're not anxious you know everything's
at least a little stable right now
please watch that video share with your
loved ones and inshallah until next time
bro
until next time
s
and you are right bro canada is
something else bro i still don't know
why i'm here bro subhanallah but uh
we'll see bro we'll see where life takes
us inshallah